did you think I was gone forever
you've committed some unspeakable crimes
Mother Gothel
and you would have continued to commit
them if Eugene hadn't cut Rapunzel's
hair the only thing you've ever cared
about was staying young and beautiful so
it was just your luck that you had to
raise a child to stay that way we just
found out one of your biggest darkest
secrets you had a daughter before
kidnapping Rapunzel oh and you're also
one of Zahn Terry's disciples Wow Gothel
just when we thought you couldn't get
any worse let's get back to your town
where you will be safe
cat is out of the bag and by that we
mean we finally know who Cassandra's
mother is Cassandra's backstory is just
as messed up as Rapunzel's so it's no
wonder they got along so famously
destroy
watch until begin to find out if there's
still hope for Cassandra or if she's
already too far gone Cassandra is a lot
of things and a good friend is one of
them or at least it used to be a lot of
people were skeptical about Cassandra
because she didn't appear to attend
Rapunzel and Eugene's royal wedding
which was curious since she and Rapunzel
were BFFs but all that changed when
Cassandra portrayed Rapunzel and stole
the moonstone opal for herself Cassandra
Cassandra's betrayal was shocking to say
the least after all she had proven
herself to be an overprotective
bodyguard and friends who legitimately
cared for Rapunzel and Eugene as well as
the kingdom of Corona so what changed
well for starters Cassandra found out
the truth about her biological mother
[Music]
therefore changing her allegiance to the
crown of Corona for good
fans of Rapunzel's tangled adventure had
long since suspected that Cassandra
would turn out to be Mother Gothel
dollar and they weren't disappointed but
it didn't make the reveal any easier to
accept as it turns out Mother Gothel was
raising a four-year-old daughter when
the Kings sent his soldiers to locate
the Sun Drop flower
despite Goethals greatest attempts to
keep the flower hidden it was found and
used to heal the Queen and her unborn
child
that's when Gothel chose to abandon her
daughter and raise her puzzle for all
the wrong reasons but it would be
decades before Cassandra found this out
in the episode titled Rapunzel topia
Rapunzel and her friends come across the
house of yesterday's tomorrow while
seeking shelter from a storm but as it
turned out the house was owned by
Troma's one of Zahn Terry's followers
you have no idea how no good I really
while Eugene and Cassandra's search for
Rapunzel Cassandra was lured into a
strange doorway at that time we weren't
shown that Cassandra had seen beyond
that point but evidently whatever she
had witnessed had changed her completely
it isn't until the third season that we
find out that Cassandra was shown a
memory of herself as a young girl and
here's where things get interesting it's
finally revealed that Mother Gothel is
Cassandra's biological mother but
instead of loving and caring for her
daughter
mother Gothel treated Cassandra just
like she had done Rapunzel while some
viewers were shocked to find out that
Mother Gothel and Cassandra were related
others weren't as surprised because well
some eagle-eyed fans had spotted their
similarities from miles away
for starters Cassandra looks exactly
like her mother they have the same black
hair red lips pale complexion and gray
eyes on top of that cassandra shares a
lot of the same personality traits as
Gothel she's stubborn vengeful and can
be two-faced when it suits her and just
like Gothel Cassandra was super
overprotective when it came to Rapunzel
sure Cassandra has some good qualities
too but clearly she's every bit her
mother's daughter you have to be careful
thankfully Cassandra was raised by an
adoptive father who happened to be the
captain of the guards he adopted
Cassandra when she was about four years
old and raised her to be loving loyal
and determined Cassandra started
training to join the guard when she was
six years old just two years after being
abandoned by her mother but despite
being raised with good values the
realization that Gothel was her
biological mother greatly impacted
Cassandra's personality her abandonment
issues bubbled to the surface causing
her to want to take the reigns into her
own hands but why would Cassandra choose
to follow in mother Gothel footsteps
after all she had exchanged her daughter
for a life of vanity as it turns out the
memory Cassandra was shown in the house
of yesterday's tomorrow was actually the
last time she'd ever seen her mom Gothel
had left cassandra behind to steal
Rapunzel from her crib at that moment
Gothel chose to abandon her daughter and
rage for puzzle in her place because
this way she could go on living a young
and beautiful life to make matters worse
Cassandra witnessed her mother leading
the guards to their home and watched as
she slipped away in the shadows never to
be heard of again in a twisted way
Rapunzel's coos and
is strange to sister but instead of
seeing Rapunzel as an ally
Cassandra chose to see her as the enemy
it was a chance to show everyone that I
am more than just your lady-in-waiting
Cassandra's jealousy was too much to
stomach in her eyes Rapunzel was the
reason for her abandonment Rapunzel had
powers parents loved ones a fortune and
on top of that she was a skilled fighter
Cassandra's jealousy led her to betray
Rapunzel in the Dark Kingdom but
Cassandra wasn't finished yet
she took things a step further by
declaring George but soon enough
Cassandra was hit with a realization
that Rapunzel was the chosen one not her
but instead of admitting defeat
Cassandra chooses to become Rapunzel's
number one enemy breaking her former
BFFs heart in the process were you
surprised to find out that Cassandra was
Mother Gothel as a biological daughter
tell us in the comments hit that
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching the
things we'll catch you next time
[Music]